Tengo 18 minutos para contarles que pasó
en los últimos seis millones de años.
(Risas)
Bien.
Todos hemos venido desde lejos,
aquí en África, y convergimos en esta región de África,
que es un lugar en donde ocurrió el 90 % de nuestro proceso de evolución.
Digo eso no por ser africano,
sino porque en África uno encuentra las pruebas más antiguas
de antepasados humanos, huellas de caminar erguidos,
hasta las primeras tecnologías en la forma de las herramientas de piedra.
Así que todos somos africanos, y bienvenidos a casa.
Bien.
Soy paleoantropólogo, y mi trabajo es definir
el lugar del humano en la naturaleza y explorar lo que nos hace humanos,
y hoy voy a usar a Selam, el infante más antiguo que se ha descubierto,
para contarles una historia de todos nosotros.
Selam es nuestro esqueleto más completo de una niña de tres años
quien vivió y murió hace 3,3 millones de años.
Pertenece a la especie conocida como Australopithecus afarensis.
No necesitan recordar eso.
Es la especie de Lucy, y fue descubierta por mi equipo de investigación
en el mes de diciembre de 2000 en una área llamada Dikika.
Está en la parte noreste de Etiopía.
Selam significa la paz en muchos idiomas Etíopes.
Usamos ese nombre para celebrar la paz en la región y en el planeta.
Y el hecho de que fue el tema de portada de todas esas revistas famosas
les da una idea ya de su importancia, creo.
Después de ser invitado por TED, hice un poco de investigación
porque eso es lo que hacemos, para enterarme de mi anfitrión.
No te lanzas a ciegas ante una invitación.
Y aprendí que la primera tecnología apareció
en la forma de las herramientas de piedra de hace 2,6 millones de años.
Pruebas del primer entretenimiento son flautas de hace 35 000 años.
Y pruebas del primer diseño vienen desde 75 000 atrás, cuentas.
Pueden hacer lo mismo con sus genes y seguirlos atrás en el tiempo.
El análisis del ADN de los humanos vivos y los chimpances nos enseña hoy
que nuestros caminos se separaron hace unos siete millones de años
y que estas dos especies comparten más que el 98 % de la misma materia genética.
Creo que saber esto es un contexto muy útil
dentro del cual podemos pensar en nuestro linaje.
Sin embargo, el análisis del DNA nos informa solamente sobre el
principio y el final, sin contarnos nada
sobre lo que pasó en el intermedio.
Así que nosotros los paleoantropólogos, debemos encontrar pruebas firmes,
evidencia fósil, para cubrir esas lagunas
y ver las diferentes etapas del desarrollo.
Porque solamente cuando se haya hecho esto que se puede hablar de...
(Risas)
porque solamente cuando se haya hecho esto que se puede hablar de
cómo parecíamos y cómo nos comportábamos en los distintos tiempos,
y cómo esos gustos, aspectos y comportamientos cambiaron con el tiempo.
Todo eso luego da un acceso
a explorar los mecanismos biológicos
y fuerzas que son responsables por estos cambios graduales
que nos hicieron lo que somos hoy.
Pero encontrar las pruebas firmes es un esfuerzo complicado.
Es un planteamiento sistemático y científico,
que te lleva a lugares lejanos, calurosos, hostiles y frecuentemente sin acceso.
Para darles un ejemplo, cuando fui a Dikika,
en donde se encontró a Selam, en 1999, --cerca de 500 kilómetros
desde Addis Abeba, la capital de Etiopía--
nos tomó apenas siete horas viajar los primeros 470 kilómetros de los 500,
pero nos tomó 4 horas completas viajar los últimos 30 kilómetros.
Con la ayuda de la gente local y usando solamente palos y picos, hice mi camino.
De hecho, fui la primera persona en conducir un vehículo hasta el lugar.
Al llegar allí, esto es lo que se ve,
y la inmensidad del lugar lo hace a uno sentirse impotente y vulnerable.
Y una vez que se llega allí, la gran pregunta es por dónde empezar.
(Risas)
No se encuentra nada por años y años.
Cuando voy a lugares así, que son sitios paleoantológicos,
es como ir a una reserva animal, una reserva de animales extintos.
Pero lo que encuentra no son los restos humanos,
como Selam y Lucy, diariamente.
Uno encuentra elefantes, rinocerontes, monos, cerdos, etcétera.
Pero podrían preguntar, ¿cómo podían estos mamíferos grandes
vivir en este ambiente desértico?
Claro que no podían, pero les digo
que el medio ambiente y la capacidad de sostenimiento
de esta región eran drásticamente distintos de lo que tenemos hoy en día.
Se podría aprender una lección sobre el medio ambiente muy importante de ésto.
Bueno, una vez allí, es una reserva animal, como dije, de animales extintos.
Nuestros antepasados vivían en esa reserva animal
pero eran solo una minoría. No fueron tan exitosos
ni tan extendidos como somos los Homo sapiens.
Para darles un solo ejemplo, una anécdota sobre su rareza,
estaba yendo a este lugar cada año y hacía trabajo de campo aquí,
y los asistentes, claro, me ayudaban a hacer los estudios topográficos.
Encontraban un hueso y decían, "Lo que busca".
Y yo, "No, es un elefante".
Luego otro, "Es un mono," "Es un cerdo," Etc.
Entonces uno de mis asistentes, que no asistió a la escuela, me dijo, "Zeray.
O no sabe qué cosa está buscando,
o está buscando en el lugar equivocado," dijo.
(Risas)
Y le dije, "¿Por qué?" "Porque había elefantes y leones,
y la gente tuvo miedo y se fue para otro lugar.
Vamos nosotros para ese otro lugar".
Estaba cansado, y el trabajo es muy pesado.
Después de mucho trabajo duro y muchos años frustrantes encontramos a Selam,
y ven la cara aquí cubierta por arenisca.
Aquí está de hecho la columna vertebral
y el torso entero recubierto de un bloque de arenisca,
porque fue enterrada por un río.
Lo que se tiene aquí no parece ser nada,
pero contiene una cantidad increíble de información científica
que nos ayuda a explorar qué es lo que nos hace humanos.
Este es el más antiguo y más completo ancestro humano juvenil
encontrado nunca en la historia paleoantropologica,
un increíble pedazo de nuestra larga, larga historia.
Había tres personas y yo, yo estoy sacando las fotos,
por eso no aparezco.
¿Cómo se sentiría en mi lugar, con algo extraordinario en la mano,
pero en medio de la nada?
Lo que sentí fue una felicidad profunda y calma y emoción,
obviamente acompañadas por un sentido de responsabilidad inmenso,
de asegurar que todo fuera seguro.
Aquí ven una foto en primer plano del fósil después de cinco años de limpiar,
preparar, y describir, que es mucho tiempo,
y me tocó liberar los huesos del bloque de arenisca
como los mostré en la diapositiva anterior.
Tardó cinco años.
Fue como el segundo nacimiento de la niña después de 3,3 millones de años,
pero fue un parto muy largo.
Aquí está a escala completa, es un hueso pequeñito.
En medio está el ministerio del turismo etíope,
que vino a visitar al museo nacional de Etiopía mientras estaba trabajando allí.
Me ven preocupado y tratando de proteger a mi hija,
porque no se deja a nadie con esta clase de niña,
ni siquiera a un ministro.
Después de haber hecho eso, el próximo paso era enterarse de qué era lo que era.
(Risas)
Una vez hecho eso, luego era posible comparar.
Pudimos averiguar que pertenecía
al árbol familiar humano porque las piernas, el pie,
y algunas características mostraron claramente que caminaba erguida,
y caminar erguido es un sello característico de la humanidad.
Pero además, si uno compara el cráneo
con un chimpancé de edad comparable y el pequeño George Bush aquí,
se ve que tiene la frente vertical,
y eso se ve en los humanos, por el desarrollo
de la corteza pre frontal, como se llama.
No se ve eso en los chimpancés,
y no se ve este diente canino tan sobresaliente.
Así que pertenece a nuestro árbol familiar, pero dentro, claro,
se hace un análisis detallado y sabemos ahora
que pertenece a la especie de Lucy,
conocida como Australopithecus afarensis.
La próxima pregunta emocionante es ¿niña o niño?,
y qué edad tenía cuando murió.
Se puede averiguar el sexo del individuo
basándose en el tamaño de los dientes.
¿Cómo?
En los primates, hay un fenómeno
que se llama dimorfismo sexual, que es que
los varones son mayores que las hembras y tienen dientes más grandes
que las hembras.
Pero se necesita la dentadura permanente,
que no se ve aquí porque lo que se tienen aquí
son dientes de leche.
Pero usando tomografía computarizada
que normalmente se usa en medicina,
se puede entrar profundamente en la boca y salir con esta bella imagen
mostrando tanto los dientes de leche aquí
y los dientes de adulto, todavía creciendo, aquí.
Al medir esos dientes,
quedó claro que empezaba a ser una niña
con dientes caninos muy pequeños.
Y para saber la edad que tenía al morir, lo que se hace es
hacer una estimación informada de cuánto tiempo hubiera sido necesario
para formar esta cantidad de dientes, y la respuesta fue tres años.
Entonces esta niña murió cuando tenía aproximadamente tres años,
hace 3,3 millones de años.
Así que con toda esa información, la gran pregunta es:
¿Qué es lo que realmente... qué nos dice ella?
Para contestarla, podemos hacer otra
¿Qué es lo que realmente sabemos sobre nuestros antepasados?
Queremos saber su apareciencia, cómo se comportaban,
cómo caminaban,
y cómo vivían y crecían.
Dentro de las respuestas que se pueden obtener de este esqueleto
se incluyen: primero, este esqueleto documenta
por primera vez la apariencia de los infantes hace más de 3 millones de años.
Y segundo, nos dice que caminaba erguida,
pero tenía alguna adaptación para escalar árboles.
Y más interesante, aun,
que su cerebro estaba todavía creciendo.
A los tres años, si se tiene un cerebro que todavía está creciendo,
es un comportamiento humano.
En chimpancés, a la edad de tres años, el cerebro ya está más del 90 % formado.
Por eso pueden con su ambiente
más fácilmente al nacer, más rápido que nosotros, en todo caso.
En los humanos, sigue creciendo el cerebro.
Es por eso que necesitamos el cuidado de nuestros padres.
Pero el cuidado quiere decir que se aprende.
Se pasa más tiempo con nuestros padres.
Y eso es muy característico de los humanos y se llama niñez,
es esta dependencia extendida de los infantes humanos
en su familia o en sus padres.
Así que el cerebro todavía creciente de este individuo
nos informa que la niñez, que requiere de
una organización social increíble,
una organización social muy compleja,
apareció hace más que tres millones de años.
Entonces por estar al cúspide de nuestra historia evolucionaria,
Selam nos une a todos y nos da una historia única
de qué es lo que nos hace humanos.
Pero no todo fue humano, y les daré
un ejemplo muy emocionante.
Este es el hueso hioides, que está justo aquí.
Apoya la lengua desde atrás.
Es, de alguna manera, caja de vos.
Determina la clase de vos que uno produce.
No fue conocido en los datos de fósiles,
y sí lo tenemos en este esqueleto.
Cuando hicimos el análisis de este hueso, quedó claro
que parecía muy chimpancé.
Entonces si uno estuviera allí hace 3,3 millones de años,
para oír cuando esta niña joven llorando por su madre,
hubiera soñado más como un chimpancé que como un humano.
Tal vez se pregunten, "Esta característica simia, esta humana, esta simia.
¿Qué nos dice eso?".
Saben, eso es muy emocionante para nosotros,
porque muestra que las cosas estaban cambiando de manera lenta y progresiva
y que la evolución de estaba dando.
Para resumir el significado de este fósil,
podemos decir lo siguiente.
Hasta ahora, el conocimiento sobre nuestros antepasados
vino esencialmente de individuos adultos
porque los fósiles, los fósiles de los bebés, hacían falta.
No se preservan bien, como bien se sabe.
Entonces el conocimiento que tuvimos sobre nuestros antepasados
sobre su aspecto, su comportamiento,
estaba en alguna medida parcial hacia los adultos.
Imagínense si viniera alguien de Marte
y su trabajo fuera reportar sobre las personas
de nuestro planeta Tierra, y se escondieran todos los bebés,
los infantes, y él regresara y diera su reporte.
¿Se pueden imaginar lo parcial que sería su reporte?
Es parecido a lo que estábamos haciendo hasta ahora
en la ausencia de los infantes fosilizados,
entonces creo que este nuevo fósil arregla la situación.
Así que al final, la pregunta más importante es,
¿qué es lo que realmente aprendemos de muestras como éstas,
y de nuestro pasado en general?
Claro, además de extraer esta cantidad inmensa
de información científica acerca de qué es lo que nos hace humanos,
los múltiples antepasados de los humanos que han existido
en los últimos seis millones de años --y hay más que 10--
no tenían el conocimiento, la tecnología, ni las sofisticaciones
que tenemos los homo sapiens hoy.
Pero si esta especie, especie antigua,
viajaría en el tiempo para vernos hoy,
estarían muy orgullosos de su legado
porque se convirtieron en los ancestros de
la especie más exitosa en el universo.
Probablemente no fueron conscientes de esta herencia,
pero lo hicieron muy bien.
La pregunta ahora es, nosotros los Homo sapiens de hoy
estamos en una posición de decidir sobre el futuro de nuestra planeta, acaso más.
Entonces la pregunta es, ¿estamos listos para el desafío?
¿Y podemos realmente hacer mejor que estos antepasados primitivos
y de cerebros pequeños?
Dentro de los desafíos más urgentes que nuestra especie
enfrenta hoy son los problemas crónicos de África.
No es necesario contarlos aquí, y hay gente más capacitada
en hablar de esto.
Sin embargo, en mi opinión, nos quedan dos posibilidades.
Una es seguir viendo una África pobre, enferma, llorando,
portando armas de fuego y que depende de otros por siempre,
o promover una África que esté llena de confianza,
pacífica, independiente, pero informada de sus grandes problemas
y de sus grandes valores a la vez.
Voy por la segunda, y estoy seguro de que muchos de Uds. están de acuerdo.
Y la clave es promover una actitud positiva hacía África.
Eso es porque nosotros los africanos nos fijamos
--soy de Etiopía, por si acaso--
nos fijamos demasiado en cómo nos ven
desde otro lado o desde afuera.
Creo que es importante promover de manera más positiva
cómo nos vemos.
Eso es lo que llamo la actitud africana positiva.
Para terminar, me gustaría decir,
ayudemos todos a que África camine erguida y hacia adelante,
así todos podremos estar orgullosos de nuestra futura herencia como especie.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)